if you if you just still long path down  to like a sentence  are you doing something for the next  generation or not the the book starts  off with the story of honey this is a  story from the talmud honey's walking  down and he sees this older man planting  a carob tree and he says you know he  goes you know why are you planting this  character you're an old man how long  does it take  for this carob tree to have fruit and  and leaves and become trees uh 30 or 40  years because well why are you planting  it then you'll be long gone  and the man answers them very simply  when i was young i played in the shade  of carob trees i ate from the fruit of  carob trees someone planted this from  for me to be in therefore i will plant  it for the next generation